this is where it all started where he
opened the door and showed them
how to become monsters
it started out as a missing teenager
i'm not able to find my daughter if she
did if she kidnapped this was the last
place brittany wood was ever seen or
heard from
two days after brittany disappeared her
uncle was found with a gunshot wound to
his head
and then the child abuse came out of the
woodwork if you can't trust your family
who can you trust
now looking back they would have been
more safe at the crack house
maybe brittany was one of the victims
for all i know he sold her because he
needed money
she was at risk of exposing this ring
this was the largest family sex abuse
case in the history of the state of
alabama
what she was protecting herself from
was them
i'm surprised anyone made it out alive
you can't help but be affected by what
that young lady went through those kids
are ruined for the rest of their lives
i'd like to find my child
my goal has always been to find brittany
wood
you